How you doing, man?
Happy night.
[Silence]
My legs aren't long enough. I reach the
floor.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us in a narration
which was collected by Muslim
on the authority of
Abdah.
He mentions that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said
for
[Silence]
It's a number of narrations put together
with different wordings. In this
narration, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam tells us that the imam has been
set in order to be followed. If we look
at the linguistic origins of the word
imm
shares origins and it shares a common
etmology with
the word em which is to be in front
of something. And so the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam here is gesturing
to the language of the narration. He's
gesturing to the language of the word,
excuse me, im linguistically. So he's
saying the im has been sent in order to
be followed.
He's been referred to as the imam in
order to be followed meaning in salah
because he is because of the word itself
means to be in front. Therefore the imam
has only been placed in order to be
followed. So what does this mean? He
goes on to elaborate. He said, "Hence,
if he says
to initiate the prayer, then say, notice
the wording here, then say
if he says Allahbar, then say Allahbar."
And this letter
this here articulates two meanings.
Okay. The first meaning is that what
comes after it is following what comes
before it in the sentence. So here he's
saying
if he is
if he says Allahbar then say Allahbar
after him. The second point to be taken
from this is that
so what this also means is that what
follows it in the sentence should come
immediately after what came before it in
the sentence. I know someone probably
listening to this is thinking, "Oh my
gosh, this guy is going into this
linguistic stuff and he's losing me."
It's it's very simple to understand this
in the Quran and elsewhere in the Arabic
language when we see it, it means that
what comes after it should follow
immediately in time what comes before it
in the sentence. So when the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam says
he says if he says Allahbar then
immediately right after say Allahbar and
we learn from this that not only are we
to follow the imam so we cannot go in
front of him or with him in the prayer
we have to follow behind and number Two,
the following of the imam should be
immediate.
It shouldn't be
u much delayed. And so the scholars of
Islam, the jurists, they took from this
that if a person
does not follow the imam within two
pillars,
then his prayer becomes invalid.
Within two pillars, what does that mean?
for instance,
standing is a pillar. Rur is a pillar.
Coming up from and standing is a pillar.
Making sujud is a pillar. Right? So two
pillars
after the im a person's salah now
becomes invalid because they're no
longer following the im. If if that
makes sense. So what this means is that
if a person were hypothetically
following the Imam and the Imam says
Allahbar and goes into and the person is
still in the standing position then the
im says Allah
and the person is still not made they
are now two pillars behind the im and
this will invalidate a person's prayer.
Okay.
Also we understand from this narration
that a person cannot go in front of the
imam because this now defeats the
purpose of the imam.
So there are four instances in following
the imam.
The narration of jab in its entirety the
imam has merely been placed in order to
be followed. He has been set as the imam
in order to be followed in prayer. Hence
if he begins with his initial
then follow him in saying Allah abbar
then say Allah abbar and if he recites
then listen
and if he goes into then go into this is
the whole narration. Now there are four
instances of how people deal with the
imam in their prayer. Number one, a
person goes ahead of the im. They make
their to initiate prayer before the im.
The imam has not reached the position of
they are in already the position of the
imam has not reached the position of
sujud. They are already ahead of him in
sujud.
This is haram. It is prohibited in the
least scenario.
The worst case scenario amongst the
scholars of had of the jurists of Islam
is that they say a person who
intentionally
goes ahead of the imam intentionally
goes in front of the imam knowing that
he is doing so his prayer is invalid for
doing this. The second instance is going
with the imam simultaneously
and this is prohibited but it will not
invalidate a person's
prayer. So for instance the im says
Allahbar and goes into and the person is
going into at the same time with the im.
This is prohibited.
The third instance is a person is
lagging way behind the imam and this is
prohibited
unless the person is behind the imam of
two or more pillars then this leads to
the invalidation of the salah. Then the
fourth and final way is the correct way
which is that a person follows
immediately the im and they move behind
the im in everything in everything right
not just injud
but even in
so for instance the imam reaches
and then people will sometimes even
sometimes jump the gun before the imam
has a chance to even finish the verse.
Right? And they are saying
right a should wait until the im begins
the
and then say it with the im. So a person
begins the im says
when they first hear the imam say to
begin the then the people behind join in
in one singular voice. This is the
proper way to follow the im. Same thing
with aim.
The im for instance begin with
to the right. A person still does not
make. He finishes to the left. Then the
person begins to make. This is the
proper way to follow the im. And you
know this is a a much more detailed
subject, but this is just to kind of get
the the questions flowing or get the
you know get the the mental juices
flowing. So inshallah as as per usual if
we have any questions we'll take
those questions now. Inshallah. Yes, we
have a we have a microphone. We got
everything set up today. This is just
for you, right? I knew you were coming.
You specifically. So, I said, "Guys, we
got to get ready for him." Okay.
[Arabic recitation]
sujud, right?
doing it. How long is it allowed to be
not to fall behind? Right? So
especially with something sjud
the the correct timing of when a person
begins to move into the next stage of
the prayer the next pillar then is once
the imam has reached that pillar.
So if we listen to for instance the
companions
and others. They said
we would stand and wait for the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam when he goes to
make sujud and each of us would stand
totally still none of us would even bend
his back to prepare to go into sujud
until we saw his forehead had reached
the ground. Now that is the ideal time
to follow the imam. Once the imam
reaches the position then you go into
it. Once the imam reaches the sitting
position then you come up from sujud.
Once the imam reaches right that's the
ideal time. But what happens sometimes
the imam is going too fast. Right? And
so if you wait that you'll be
behind him.
You never want to in the worst case
scenario go past following the imam
directly.
Right? You never want to reach the
position where you are going
simultaneous with the imam. That is the
point that you never want to go to. Even
if you're following an imam that is
going too quickly. If the imam is going
so fast that you are unable to keep a
very tight following of him, then the
prayer anyways may be incorrect. And so
what would you do in this situation? I
think most of us have kind of been in
this situation where you're following an
im and he's going so fast that you're
not having the ability to say subhah
once and find complete stillness
in that position which is referred to as
so in this case the tell us that you
should break off and start making your
own salah on your own. What does that
mean? So the imam is going so fast you
can't follow him. You don't have to
leave the place that you're in. But you
now start to make your prayer on your
own and your prayer will be valid.
Understood? You get what I mean? Now
[Arabic recitation]
parents, you know, to teach the kids
because this is when they're young, you
know, that's when they learn.
[Arabic recitation]
The the where does teaching come from,
right? If you look at
all the narrations we have of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam in
the most generous estimates
counting weak narrations
we have
around 30,000 narrations without
repetition. Now these narrations can
range anywhere from a single word to a
long hutwa that he gave or even a
something that he did. This is all
counted as a narration. 30,000
narrations.
You count that against 23 years
that is a little that's not very much is
it? I if you think about 23 years how
much does a person speak
in one day? How much does a person speak
in one in one year? If you had someone
following you write in everything or the
angels that are writing, if you could
look at what they're writing, how much
there could there be? Much more than
30,000. Should be more 300 or maybe
even 3 million narrations, right?
300,000.
What does this articulate? That he spoke
very little and did very much. And most
of the things that he did was
repetition,
right? He would say the same thing over
and over and over. He would teach the
same thing over and over and over until
people understood until it became part
of the culture. And this is not enough
to just be oh the said or the helps but
that's not how we solve problems. How do
we solve problems? By doing by action.
Now,
[Arabic recitation]
Oh, we got There we go.
we follow what we hear or what we see?
If you're able to see the IM, you should
always look at the IM, especially when
he is changing positions.
You always look at the imam and
especially when he is changing
positions.
However, if you're follow if you're
unable to see the imam, you should
follow those who are following him.
[Arabic recitation]
the because we see this sometimes
Very good question. Does he follow all
the time even if you forget? Okay, so we
have a situation. Here's the here's the
circumstance.
The person is following the im. If the
imam forgets something and leaves it
out.
Okay?
And he reaches the next pillar then you
follow him.
Now this is with leaving it out. Leaving
out something
then you follow the im. So for instance
let's say the im forgets the first
in a prayer that has more than one. He
forgets it. He stands straight up. If he
has reached the position of standing,
then you follow the iman, right?
However,
if it is the case of adding to the
prayer, so let's say we're praying
behind an im and she Ali is, you know,
elsewhere today, right? Or sheh is
elsewhere today and he's leading us in
salah and he's got some on his mind. And
so after the fourth raka, he stands up
for the fifth.
And we all know for sure that this is
the fourth raqa. He has just stood up
for a fifth. Do we follow him or not? It
is impermissible to follow him in this
case. Why? Because knowingly adding a
pillar to prayer invalidates it. So
there's a difference between missing and
adding. Right? Now what if the im stands
up for the fifth raq and we all know
that it is the fourth we are positive of
this and we say subhan allah but the
imam
he doesn't agree he disagrees and he
insists on praying the fifth raqa what
do we do we stay seated and wait for him
to come back to us we do not add a
pillar knowingly to the prayer it would
be the same as adding two or making a
third saga right knowingly adding a
prayer to to adding a pillar to the
prayer invalidates the prayer. So this
is a very very good question actually
and if the imam reaches that position
then he shouldn't go back down into the
the u the for instance the first yes
[Arabic recitation]
third same thing same ruling book same
ruling yes next question Abu Ali here
all the way in the
in the corner there.
[Arabic recitation]
make sujud
the sujud of forgetfulness in a prayer
that is not the obligatory prayer.
Soju
for those who don't know if a person
forgets something in prayer forgets to
add something mistakenly or forgets
something mistakenly or what have you
there's instances for
then at the very end after the person
then makes two sujud either before or
after this is what he's asking about and
the question is do you make sujud in the
salam
meaning not
for rather you're just making two for
instance
and you miss something do you make the
answer is yes the majority of the
scholars of Islam hold the view that is
applicable to any prayer
whether it be an obligatory prayer or a
an optional one
[Arabic recitation]
This guy over here.
What would we do without fat? Seriously,
the masid is going to fall apart without
this guy. Go ahead.
[Arabic recitation]
to the subject of the narration you
mentioned which is following the imam.
what about saying a mean after a
fat? Do we wait for the imam to say a
mean and say it afterwards or do we say
it simult simult simultaneously with
the with the imam
[Arabic recitation]
is an incredible act of worship.
I want to say this, this is a little bit
off the question, but it's important
information. It is an incredible act of
worship. Imagine what is mean? What does
the meaning of?
It means it is.
It is the name of a ver verb which means
Oh Allah, please answer our dua. Answer
our supplication.
Now imagine this. You are with your
brothers and sisters in prayer. The imam
says
and then we all together
say
together in one voice
begging Allah until the walls shake.
Please Allah
answer our dua. That's what is and that
is why it is so important and that is
why the reward for is so great in Bkari
the prophet sallall.aii mentions
that when the Imam says
the angels say amen
he says and hence whoever's
coincides
with the angels
what is passed of his sins will be
forgiven.
That is an that's the narration is it's
an incredible narration. Correct? I mean
for such a small thing seemingly this is
the reward. Well, why is that reward so
great for such a seemingly simple act
of worship? The reason isn't because of
how hard or difficult or easy the act
of worship is, but because of what the
act of worship represents.
It is a group of Allah's slaves that got
together to to to
beg to the heavens. Oh Allah, forgive us
and answer our prayers. It's an
incredible act of worship. And so for
this reason
he mentions when the used to take place
in the time of the companions
he mentions Abdullahn Zuber Abdullahn
Zuber he is considered of the companions
even though he doesn't fit exactly what
a companion is because Abdullahn Zuber
was a baby he was very young who's a
toddler when the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam passed away. However,
what Abdullahbn Zub said or did is
extremely important from a perspective.
Why? Because number one, we know all of
his teachers were what? Companions.
Number two, he was the Amir of Mecca for
a long time, for a time. and the most
knowledgeable of the senior companions
were there with him in Mecca and would
agree with the things that he said and
the things that he did. Alm Bkari said
that Abdullahbn Zub
when he was the the of Mecca when he
would say
the people would then say with him with
him
in one united voice until the masid
would shake and rumble from the sound.
That is what it was described as right
in.
And so what do we understand from this?
We understand that once the im begins to
say am you don't go before him. Once you
hear the im say and that's how this the
write it in that way. Once he begins
with the first vowel of which is the al
if
once you hear that you then begin to say
it with him and finish together
and if your
coincides with the tet of the im and
finishes with him and doesn't start
before him that is when your tet
coincides with the tet of the angels
does that make sense Now,
any more questions? We have about 3
or 4 minutes left.
[Arabic recitation]
in salah and does it invalidate salah?
question. What is considered to be
excessive movement in salah and does it
invalidate your prayer? First of all,
the scholars all agree this is an issue
of
all of the four
including
all agree
that excessive movement in the prayer
invalidates your prayer. But the
question now is what is the gauge or the
yard stick or the metric for excessive
movement. Right?
We have to first understand what is
meant by movement. When the fuka say
movement,
they're not speaking about any movement.
They're speaking about movement that
does not serve the prayer.
We understand that movement that does
not serve the prayer. So for instance,
let's say we didn't have a microphone
system the way it was. Okay? Let's say
the imam has to hold the microphone in
his hand. Holding the microphone in his
hand and placing it down when he goes
for a sujud and reaching out to grab it
and so forth. That is movement. That's
not part of the prayer. Correct? But it
is movement that serves the prayer.
Understood?
That's an important distinction because
some people and I I've even had this
happen before where brothers will read
in a book of that says you know
three or more movements or excessive
movement invalidates the prayer and they
think that their prayer is invalid if
the imam holds the microphone. Right?
This is not what the fuka are speaking
about when they say excessive movement
invalidates prayer. They are speaking
about movement that does not serve the
prayer. Right? how do we know this?
Well, first of all, when the prophet
sallallah.aii was first received
revelation to start praying towards
Mecca and he was in Medina.
Some narrations place this as others
place it as whatever it is when he
received that in his masid the other
massid haven't receive that message yet
they're still praying towards Maktis
which is the opposite direction
and so one of the companions and the
narration is in Bkari came across
another group of companions that were
praying Jama And they were praying
towards Betal Makis.
And he said to them while they were in
prayer, I hereby testify that I just
prayed with the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and salah has now
been redirected to masid haram.
So the companions in Rur, they were in
Rur turned around in their prayer while
in Rur simultaneously
and then continued their prayer and it
wasn't viewed as invalid. Now this is
one instance of many. Now how much
movement took place for that that
coordination to happen? If you could
imagine that kind of coordination and no
less. Therefore, we see that none of the
companions that were in that prayer or
others viewed that as invalidating the
prayer even though it was much excessive
movement. Why? Because it was excessive
movement that what serves the prayer.
Okay. Now, let's speak about excessive
movement that does not serve the prayer.
scratching my head or you know someone
or me messing around with their clothes
or something that. That does not
serve the prayer. That excessive
movement breaks salah. It will
invalidate a person's salah. Now the
scholars agree on that. They differ on
what is the threshold of excessive
because
non- excessive or you know acts that
are not too excess they will not break
the prayer they will not invalidate the
prayer but what is the threshold and the
the point of no return between excessive
and not some scholars say well they give
it a number so they say two or three
movements. Some say three movements,
right? And these three movements have to
be in succession, one right after the
other. So he he straightens his glasses,
straightens out his his ths with his
beard or his hat or something that.
Three in quick succession that breaks
the prayer. However, there's no number
set for this. The correct opinion is
that if it reaches the degree where
someone watching you would not know that
you are in prayer because of the
movement that will invalidate the salah.
Does that make sense? So let's say a
person is actually praying but when you
walk in you see them adjusting and
drying their face off because they were
making woo or what have you. And to the
onlooker this person is not in salah. it
looks he's getting ready to make
salah for instance that person's salah
will now be invalidated with that
excessive movement and this all roots
back to a principle in
that the scholars all agree on and that
is
which is a can of worms that we're not
going to open right now but that is
where they get this from now one we
could have one last question inshallah
on the im that he misses the four and
stand for number five.
[Arabic recitation]
salah.
So what are the ruling? Is it a valid
salah or the individual has to come and
do the again? No. The prayer is valid
and even if the im does not do
the people behind him don't do
in is only made when the im makes sujud
the prostration of forgetfulness. What
if a person forgets to make the
prostration of forgetfulness?
Right? The prayer is valid.
Seven, even if it is left off
intentionally in the correct opinion,
will not invalidate a person's prayer.
I'll repeat that sujud
even if left off intentionally,
knowingly
will not invalidate a person's prayer.
Will it diminish it? Yes. Diminish the
reward? Yes. Have they done something
wrong? Yes. But it will not invalidate a
person's prayer because it is not an
integral part of salah.
Therefore, let's say the imam makes a
mistake or let's say you are praying
behind the im and you make a mistake
that warrants
and if you were praying alone you would
have made sujud
do you make sujud behind the im after
the answer is no. If you are being led
by someone else in salah
and the only instance in which you would
make as being led would make sujud is if
the im makes sujud. If he does not, you
do not make sujud.
And this goes back to a narration of the
prophet Sam
in a
he says saiam
the im is a guarantee
for your prayer and the is entrusted
with making. We don't have to double
check the when he makes that that it was
on time or he is in charge of that when
he makes who and if he makes a mistake
in the that mistake is not on us because
he was entrusted with that and
meaning in the im is a guarantee
which means if you make a a mistake in
your prayer but you're praying behind an
im the im absorbs verbs that in the
sense that your salah is valid as long
as his salah is valid. Now notice we're
talking about what? Mistakes. We're not
talking about intentional, right?
Intentionally leaving something off.
Now there's another narration in a for
instance
he said sallallahu alaihi wasallam
regarding the imams of prayer if they
are correct then it is in your favor and
theirs and if they make a mistake it is
in your favor and against them that is
upon them not upon the person being led
in prayer. Okay.
Alhamdulillah.